e
dans les environs d'arcachon un couple
de retraité vit depuis plus de 35 ans en
électricité pour en bénéficier
l'edf leur réclame la somme de 155 mille
francs rien que ça
[Musique]
arcachon de payants
où
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
-
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce que c'est que la faire
bouder les bouder sont des gens de très
braves gens vraiment de très braves gens
que j'aime bien qu'ils m'aiment bien je
crois c'est vraiment le très braves gens
dignes d'intérêt eelv habite une petite
maison naguère il a connu la guerre que
ces poutres et chevron qui est en très
bon état sont à combiers ma fac et quand
même admire allemands placés qui est à
deux pas de la route 25 et 50 mètres de
la route nationale des lacs
c'est tout un programme en pleine forêt
et avait quand même propriété qui lui
appartient de 17 hectares passé vers les
années 20 58 de 58 60 il y a eu dans le
cadre du message et culture avec la du
département de conseil général de
l'époque les syndicats d'électricité je
sais quoi exactement
je n'ai aucun souvenir de ces temps
lointains il ya une politique
d'aménagement des quartiers non équipés
en électricité qui ont été équipés avait
les crédits spéciaux qui n'ont pas coûté
d'argent aux gens qui te sens lumière
c'est ce qu'on appelait le programme
d'électrification des écarts ce qui est
certain c'est que pour les raisons qui
sont ce qu'elles sont les bouder n'ont
pas voulu je crois que les poteaux passe
dans deux propriétés j'en sais rien en
tout cas ils n'ont pas la lune le beau
fils de monsieur goudé avait cru au
président de la république qui a répondu
le public averti le préfet lequel préfet
m'a averti et ses terrasses et la
cascade habituel bon ce qui est sûr
c'est que ce procès république va
trouver des crédits spéciaux à le préfet
non plus par les partenariats dans une
addition dead et d'efforts qui va être
obligatoirement nécessaire pour arriver
à faire une opération qui d'ailleurs
sera une sorte de passe droit je tiens
vous le dire parce qu'actuellement
telles vues jamais à sa maison qui
s'effondre pourquoi la collectivité
locale ne reflètent elles passaient près
de charpente
vous comprenez bon alors il s'agit là
d'un précédent la précédence social
c'est vrai bon il faudra bien le
résoudre il sera tranché et j'ai
programmé dans les têtes dans les jours
qui viennent
l'union et tous les services concernés
ou qui devraient être concernés pour
essayer de trouver une solution à ce
problème
je tiens à dire quand même madame quelle
que soit la sympathie que j'ai pour le
bout du nez comme pas un
un problème de
les gens savent aussi moi j'ai toujours
voulu la lumière j'ai toujours voulu
mais c'est le voisin qui n'a pas voulu
comme passe dans sa propriété il n'a pas
voulu faire tomber les arbres pour la
lumière chez le voisin
il voulait passer alors si l'ancien
maire avait dit vous faites le tour
c'était pas pour un poteau de plus ça
faisait je sais pas moins huit ou neuf
pour tous c'était tout s'il avait exigé
c'était j'aurais eu la lumière comme les
autres
les derniers instants samedi c'est de
manier 73 de manière 75e demander tout
le temps on m'a toujours dit oui mais je
ne voit toujours rien venir
en 91 je suis trouvé au repas des
vieillards des vieux quoi et j'ai
demandé à monsieur le maire de recevoir
m'a dit oui à nice samedi
je suis allé le le samedi là bas il m'a
frei avait été la deuxième la troisième
et moi on m'a passé la dernière et
encore je lui ai forcé années m'a reçu
je lui ai dit rien pour moi le bien il
valait comment voulez vous que je trouve
cet argent pour vous donner la lumière
mais moi je n'ai pas d'argent pour
participer avec 7 à l'électrification
car jason nous avons à tous les deux
prouver aux 3500 francs par mois alors
nous ne pouvons pas
pour ne pouvons pas fournir de donner de
l'argent j'ai cité de face pour mettre
l'argent et du moment qu'on a mis pour
les autres courriers mon mari il a donné
même un mort sur le terrain pour là pour
faire la route qui est qu'ils fassent la
de 23 5 90 m de terrain sur 15 mètres de
large
il nous a jamais été payés que nous
appris mais on nous a pas demandé
combien vous devez alors j'estime gains
qui peuvent quand même drôle et mettre
aujourd'hui la lumière de la bougie a
fait une nouvelle demande d'alimentation
et nous lui avions transmis un nouveau
devis actualisé qui est aujourd'hui 250
5000 francs la maison dessus et mahmoud
et et environ 1 900 mètres du réseau
électrique
aujourd'hui ce qui veut dire que pour
alimenter ces personnes il nous faut
environ avec une équipe de travail de
deux personnes en gros une semaine
et nous avons à ce moment là planté une
douzaine de supports dont deux poteaux
béton bois plus le câble électrique pour
les alimenter alors effectivement on
peut trouver que le devis est excessif
est très lourd pour une famille qui a
semble-t-il des revenus assez moyen
paris c'est plus pénible
salah d'arthrose et là sa maladie c'est
dur pour elle maintenant j'ai 74 ans et
je ne peux plus mon mari à 71 à 72
benneteau et ne peut guère non plus vous
savez ça sans lumière sans c'est très
dur sans avoir peur au moins le minimum
de confort je pense qu'on pourrait le
faire quelque chose pour nous parce que
d'après tôt en avons nous avons toujours
voté nous avons toujours été bon citoyen
je crois de plus jamais ça on ne peut
pas se plaindre de nom je crois qu'on
pourrait nous faire faire quelque chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a fait revoter j'avais entendu parler
concernant le manque d'électricité
paraît-il que monsieur ce monsieur n'a
pas hésité dans les bois depuis trop
longtemps que 55
parce que il a peut-être eu l'occasion
en ce moment de profiter des avantages
je dirais même gratuits vont mais il
savait en commun train de cette
affaire-là on a fait une affaire d'état
que jamais ça se monte à l'index
parce qu'il ya un monsieur qui n'a pas
voulu
il n'a pas accepté pour quelles raisons
libre à lui les excités en arriver là
son âge quand même ça me fait dur je
regrette de bout en bout de ce qui lui
arrive qu'est ce que vous voulez c'est
comme ça le reste viendra peut-être
alors serait-il et la lumière
c'est sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
où